à toulouse météo france estime que c'est
la tempête la plus grave que la france
ait connu depuis une cinquantaine
d'années un phénomène météorologique
dont l'ampleur était difficilement
prévisibles reportage de dorothée
cochard et david bres fujitsu vpp 700 un
nom bien barbare pour une machine fort
élaboré à l'abri isolé dans les sous
sols de météo france toulouse ce
superordinateur traite plusieurs
centaines de milliards d'opérations par
seconde
il réceptionne des données observées
dans le monde entier et l'abordé
prévisions qui apparaissent quasi
instantanément sur les ordinateurs des
météorologues
un outil précieux efficace mais jamais
suffisant qui dit prévisions dit
incertitudes ainsi si on savait ce qui
se passera demain offre pas de la
prévision au frais du pronostic
donc la difficulté c'est de prendre en
compte ce qui se passe aujourd'hui ce
que nos modèles mathématiques prévoit
pour demain après-demain et de
d'utiliser pour ça pour essayer de
coller au plus juste à ce qui se passera
réellement et les météorologues avaient
bien prévu cette tempête d'une rare
violence venus d'outre-atlantique
en revanche ce qui était quasi
impossible à prévoir avec précision ce
sont les mini tourbillon si dévastateur
qui se sont formés à l'intérieur même de
cette dépression je vais donner un
exemple simple prenez un prenez une
tasse de café le matin et donner un
petit coup de cuillère à l'intérieur
vous allez voir apparaître un certain
nombre de tourbillon et certains de ces
tourbillons sont d'une échelle tout à
fait microscopiques et se forment son
ensemble ne sachiez pourquoi seule
certitude ce soir une autre dépression
gagne en ce moment même le nord du pays
ces rafale devrait encore dépasser les
100 km heure